uh were you able to perform on stage at
all this summer yes
you know so i um i went out to yellow
springs ohio
to dave chappelle's dave chappelle has a
like like a summer camp going on with
his performances that a covet you know
everybody is socially distanced uh or
physically distance however you want to
say it
um and people we all get cover tested
it's great comedians i mean from sarah
silverman to tiffany hattis to
to um my man muhammad to dave himself
it's like some of the best comedians
michael che
um jon hamm was out there we had a great
time but we also performed quest love
from the roots erica badu
and it felt so great to be on stage it's
like you
you you remember the joy of what it is
when you're on stage like the not only
the joy for you but the joy you're able
to give
people i think that's i mean i don't
know for you but for me
being on stage is like you sharing a
gift like you're the vessel you're the
vessel
yeah and you and you receive energy from
the crowd but you also give energy
so it was just a it was just a blessing
to be there we all were like
energized by getting where y'all all
like this is my dream movie of all the
people that you just said
so we're all all on stage at certain
points together like doing stuff
together oh yeah we were together
because
as soon as we arrived in yellow springs
you get culvert tests
and so at that point we get our little
little
um wrist i'm healthy abandoned i'm good
and everybody feels a little more
comfortable it's you know it's it's a
transition for people because you know
we all coming from
the world where we like wearing the mask
but once we got culver tested it's a
it's a small amount of people
that are around and um you know but it's
a great crowd like
everybody people come from all over the
midwest mostly ohio and yellow springs
is a great town shout out to yellow
springs i love
this town it's like a hippie town in the
middle of ohio a small place and dave is
like the american
yeah it's very artistic i bought palo
santo and different little antique
things there i love it
oh that's so cool and what a what a way
to navigate what's going on
you know what i'm saying like to for it
not to completely stop everyone and
their creativity and their
expression and inspiring people that's
that's a really really cool way to do
[Music]
that